I am the editor founder of the gry
zone.com we're an independent website
cuz you really can't say anywhere
outside of Independent Media these days
uh most of the people I work with all of
them can't work in media and we focus
mostly on issues of Empire uh foreign
policy we try to touch the third rail
say what other people say say what isn't
being said um and I think our work
really speaks for itself and we try to
focus on reporting investigative
journalism and not you know strident
commentary we do lots of video work we
do a stream every week I've written four
books I've done two books on Israel
Palestine wow um Goliath and the 51-day
war where I covered the is the war in
Gaza in 2014 which lasted for 51 days
and I've done a documentary about that
called killing Gaza which is free on
YouTube um you can find it at the
greyzone YouTube channel